It was early dawn
on the day before Christmas.
The city was still asleep.
That is, most of the
city was still asleep.
Others were already up
and about their business.
The story you're about to see is true.
I know, it happened to me.
I can't tell you where
or when it happened.
There are still people around,
people who never forget,
and I'd like to keep on living.
My name? Let's just say it's Casey Martin.
- What's the matter?
- Out.
I'll drive him around till he wakes up.
See you tonight at Louie's place.
I didn't know it yet,
but this was going to be my big day,
my big opportunity; my Christmas present.
December 24th, a day I'll never forget.
Take it easy, will ya Jack?
- Excuse me, miss.
- Joe, help him out.
How many times I gotta tell you, Casey?
You don't start fights in here.
- Oh, shut up, Louie.
- Shut up, he said.
Try to bust the joint up
and tells me to shut up.
Come on, come on. Alright.
- Merry Christmas.
- What's merry about it?
- You know, the trouble with you
is you know too much about psychiatry.
- You have to!
Otherwise you develop little
mental blocks and things.
Here comes a couple of live ones.
- What is it, what do you want?
What do you want?
- You.
Why?
- Tell you all about it, come on.
- Land of the free!
- Too free for some of us.
When the boys from
the Treasury Department pick you up,
believe me, it's no
ordinary two bit pinch.
When the government steps
in, you're in trouble.
Real trouble.
I had that all gone feeling
right in the middle of my stomach.
The feeling that the roof had caved in
and there wasn't much use
of trying to dig my way out.
What is this?
- You're Casey Martin?
- That's right.
- How much time have
you served Mr. Martin?
- Nine years, why?
- Sit down.
I asked you to sit down, Mr. Martin.
Leavenworth: three years, three months.
Back again two years, six months.
Atlanta, four years.
Now you're out two weeks
and you're in trouble again.
- What do you mean?
- Well, a four time loser can spend
the rest of his life
in prison, Mr. Martin.
- What are you driving at?
So?
- That your brand?
- I mix 'em up.
- Oh?
-Why?
- We found this package
at the spot where a truck was hijacked.
- Well?
- We found your
fingerprints on the package.
- That's a lie.
- Send in Mr. Sears.
Do you recognize this man Mr. Sears?
Take off your hat.
- He's one of them.
- Thank you, you can go.
- Well, that's it Mr. Martin.
What do you intend doing about it?
- What can I do?
- After a man reaches a certain age,
there's only one way he can
break loose from the underworld.
He's got to blast himself
loose with a big bang.
Make a big move, burn all his bridges;
turn his life upside down if necessary.
- What do you mean?
We want you to work with us.
- You've been in trouble all your life.
We're offering you a
chance to break clean.
- What are you talking about?
- We're giving you an opportunity
to get yourself killed.
Look, you know the mobs, how they operate.
One strong, ruthless man can
tie a syndicate together.
He pushes the buttons
and pulls the strings
and all over the nation,
his vicious rackets are set in motion.
He's a dictator.
We are after one of those dictators.
We want him bad.
- Who?
- Dutch Becker.
- Good luck.
Put the finger on
him and you're a free man.
- You're kidding.
-Am I?
- Listen mister,
I spent two extra years in stir
because I wouldn't tell
him who my partner was.
I was brought up that way.
I don't intend to change now.
- Look, you know Dutch
Becker as well as I do.
He has no conscience, he has no soul.
It makes no difference to him
if he destroys an individual
or a family or a nation.
And enough men like Becker
could destroy a nation.
- You picked me up on a meatball charge.
Why don't you pick him up?
- Because he is too smart.
We can't prove a thing, yet.
His lawyers would have
him out in 10 minutes.
- That's your problem.
- Yes, and that's a big one.
Nine states big.
We know that Becker is operating
in at least nine states.
California, Oregon, New York, New Jersey,
Illinois, Minnesota,
Missouri, Arizona, and Nevada.
He gets his cut out of
everything rotten that's sold.
We want him.
Let me show you something.
Here's a girl, 17.
Dead before she even started to live.
Sixteen, twenty.
There's a girl, nineteen.
They found her in a trunk.
She wanted to go home to her family,
but the boys couldn't see it her way.
The hospitals, jails, asylums, and morgues
are full of human beings
who were destroyed
by men like Dutch Becker.
- You seen your sister lately?
- Lucille? No, Why?
- Just wondered.
- A man ought to keep in
closer touch with his family.
- I haven't been around, remember?
Yeah, we know.
- You can go now, Casey.
Think it over: the rest of your
life in jail is a long time.
Let us know what to decide,
we'll give you four hours.
- You're getting a break, Casey.
Don't throw it away.
- Call getting myself killed a break?
Drop over and
see your sister, Casey.
She won't be there tomorrow.
-Why?
- Just drop over and see her.
She might help you make up your mind.
It isn't often
anyone gets a break like that.
I was offered a clean bill of health,
my freedom, a new start.
All I had to do was put
the finger on Dutch Becker.
I'd been around long enough to know
all there is to know about Dutch Becker.
He was one of the biggest
gamblers in the country.
He was the kingpin in a
nationwide illegal alcohol ring.
He employed beautiful girls as escorts,
hostesses, shills, and bee girls
in his clubs and gambling houses.
If they crossed him,
they weren't very pretty to
look at when he paid them,
and he always did.
This was the man they
wanted me to double cross.
I hadn't seen Lucille for a long time,
but I remember that she loved the bottle.
She loved the bottle more than life.
Maybe she was on it again.
- Hi honey.
- Casey?
- Yeah.
- Are you really Casey?
- Yeah, I'm Casey.
- Oh!
I'm so glad to see ya.
I'm so glad!
- Gee Junie, you've grown up.
Hows your mommy?
- I think she's sleeping.
She's sick, Casey.
I've been trying to help her, but,
I'm scared Casey.
- All right, sweetheart.
All right, okay.
- Junie,
Junie,
that you, Junie?
Junie.
Casey?
Casey.
Don't let him take me away, Casey.
Don't let him take me away.
- You stupid fool.
- You all right, Mommy?
- Get that kid outta here!
- Mommy!
- Get out of here!
- Get out, get out!
- Lucille, stop!
- My baby, my little baby.
- But she wants me, Casey.
-All right, sweetheart. Come here.
Have you got a phone book?
- In the hall.
-Alright, now you look
up a Dr. Charles Joyce
on East Fourth Street.
Then you call him up
and you tell him your uncle Casey Martin
wants him to come over here right away.
Can you do that?
Okay, sweetheart. Go on.
How long you been on this?
- I don't know, I don't know.
You gotta help me.
I hurt so bad.
Get me a drink, Casey. Please!
- No, I won't get you nothing.
- Listen, they say I'm crazy.
They're gonna take Junie away from me.
I'm not crazy, I'm not!
- What happened to you?
- Oh don't, Casey. Please!
- Why are you doing this to yourself?
Why?
You know Dutch Becker?
- That's funny. That's very funny!
- Do you know him?
- I used to be the prettiest
girl ever worked for Dutch.
You hear that Casey?
I used to be the prettiest
girl ever worked for Dutch.
I used to be proud.
Now I got no pride.
All the looks, nothing.
- What about your little girl?
You've got her, what about her?
- Don't, don't. Can't you
see it's killing me, Casey?
Can't you see it?
- I can't, I can't, I can't!
- Lucille!
- I can't, I can't!
- Burns speaking.
Yeah, put him on.
Casey.
Good.
What's that?
Okay, Casey.
We'll let your doctor handle it.
Yeah, I know.
Yeah, how's 10 in the morning?
Fine, see you then.
We've got our man.
- Hi Casey.
- Hi.
- What am I, an orphan?
- Hi Gladys.
I got a gland for you.
- Oh, that's good. That's good.
- Good? Is that all you can say?
- What do you want me to do, kiss you?
- Hey, you loaded?
- You might be able to say that.
- What are you folks having?
Gladys?
- Scotch over.
- Lefty?
- No thanks.
- You nuts or something,
getting loaded today?
- Today is the day to get loaded, Lefty.
Today is definitely the day.
- What are you talking about?
- It's a big day.
It's a day to celebrate.
- You off your rocker?
- You all right?
I'm alright.
- Look, Case,
it's a big load coming through tonight.
Go on home, take a bath,
sober up and we'll talk.
- Forget it, we're through.
- What?
- I said, we're through.
-Why?
- Take a long trip, Lefty.
Just take a long trip.
- Talk sense, will ya Case?
Talk sense.
I got a tip
and that's a good one.
Just take a long trip.
You on the level?
- There's one of two
things that you can do.
You can get outta here,
or you can shut up and have a drink.
Which one? I don't care.
- You coming with me?
- No.
- What?
- I said no.
- Okay, okay.
Where do I get in touch with you?
Don't.
- What?
- I said, don't.
- All right.
- Coming with me, Gladys?
- I'll buy you a drink.
- You're buying, I'm staying.
- You wouldn't be trying to
pull a cross with you, Case?
- Did you ever know me
to double cross anybody?
I want my money.
Merry Christmas.
- Merry Christmas Casey.
- Ah, pour yourself one.
- Thanks.
Happy holiday, folks.
- This is nice.
- Yeah.
- What's the matter with you tonight?
Something bothering you?
- Fella told me something today.
He said if I wanted to get any place,
I'd have to make a big move.
Burn my bridges behind me,
turn my life upside down.
That's what I'm gonna do.
- How?
- You know Dutch Becker?
How well do you know him?
- Why?
- Wanna meet him.
- Why do you wanna meet him?
- Well, he knows how to make money.
I want some of it.
- I don't like that kind of money, Casey.
- It'll spend.
- You spend it.
Oh, forget Dutch, Casey.
You don't need him.
- Forget I talked to you.
- Hi, handsome.
- Hi Mother.
- Mother?
- Come on, beat it will ya?
- You've got a lot of nerve.
- Yeah, I know.
Here, Merry Christmas.
- Happy New Year.
- You like music, don't you?
- Yeah, I like it.
- I like you.
You win, Casey.
- When do I meet him?
- Anytime you say.
I'll call you later.
- Where you going?
- Out.
- Well, what do you think?
- I think he'll show.
- I give him 15 more minutes
and then I'll put out a pickup on him.
Hello, Casey.
- Hi.
- You know Johnny Cooper, Fred Amory.
Dick Sullivan, Jim Rogers, Ted Wheelock,
Al Chance, Frank Sallow, Bud Anderson.
I've seen you before.
- Could be you'll see more of me.
- Did you ever meet Dutch?
- No.
- Well, he's shrewd and he's tough.
Make no mistake about that.
One bad move and it may be your last.
- Yeah.
- Came from the same
neighborhood, didn't you?
- Yeah, but I don't know him.
- You have an important asset.
Loyalty to your friends, they trust you.
- So what do I do?
- Can you fix a meet with him?
- I think so.
- How?
- You know a girl named Gladys Baker?
- Well, I know she's made
a few contacts for you.
- Well, she doesn't know it yet,
but she fixes me with Dutch.
Then you'll kill all your
charges against her, right?
- Right.
- Better build it up
soft and slow, Martin.
Get his confidence.
- Listen, Mr. Sullivan, that right?
- That's right.
- Okay, Mr. Sullivan, I took this job.
When I take a job, I do it right.
- You sure you could handle it?
- Well, who can be sure of anything?
What do you want me to get him on?
- That's up to you.
It's wide open, take your choice.
Just be sure we can make it stick.
Oh, and don't get any ideas
about running out on us.
We'll be watching you every minute.
- Yeah.
- All right, you're on your own, Casey.
Good luck.
Well there it
was, laid right in my lap.
I come out clean or I come out dead.
The Treasury Department and
the police were on my side.
Against me, there was a big time hoodlum
by the name of Dutch Becker,
and the entire underworld
from coast to coast.
There wasn't a gambler alive
who'd make book with those odds.
- Hello?
Gladys?
- Yeah.
- Casey.
- Oh! Oh, am I glad to hear from you.
I thought you might've
changed your mind about me.
- When can I meet Dutch?
- Why don't you forget him?
I still don't like it.
- When can I meet him?
- Well, he has lunch every day
at his Torch Club down on East 12th.
- Good, now you meet me there at 12:30
and you'll make like
you got a date with me.
- But,
- Yeah, 12:30.
- That stuff will kill you, Dutch.
- Uh-uh, keep me healthy.
Get my friend a drink.
- Thanks, scotch over rocks.
- Want something to eat?
- No, I've got a date.
Fella who grew up down
here, maybe you know him.
- Who's that?
- His name's Casey Martin.
- Yeah, I heard of him.
You know him, Lou?
- Yeah.
I saw him every day for
four years in Atlanta.
I don't like him.
You don't like nobody.
- Nobody, exceptin' you Dutch.
- Yeah, exceptin' me.
You tell me that this
Martin boy's pretty smart,
knows how to keep his mouth shut?
I'd like to meet him, all right?
- Okay.
Dutch, I like him.
Don't ever tell him
anything about me, please?
- I don't know what you're talking about.
- Thanks.
- Swiss cheese on rye
and a glass of milk.
- Coming up.
- Bring him over.
- I will.
- Lonesome?
- Hi.
Make it good, he's here.
- Where is he?
- Table right behind
you, over by the wall.
We're lucky, he wants to meet you.
- Nice company he keeps.
Had enough?
- Mm-hm.
- Okay, let's go.
- Dutch?
This is Casey. Martin.
Casey, Mr. Becker.
- Hi.
- Sit down.
You know Lou.
- I know him.
- Yeah, we were memes.
One with big shot.
- You were a pretty hot kid
around this neighborhood,
a couple of years back.
- I got along.
- What are you doing now?
- I get along.
- You got a good mouth, keep it closed.
- Gladys said you wanted to see me.
- She did?
- Yeah, why?
- Well, maybe just to prove
that I'm not antisocial.
- Maybe I am. C'mon.
- I like you up to now.
Don't spoil it.
- You know Mister, for a long time
people were telling me
what to say and what to do.
Now I'm my own boss.
- Jack,
couple of drinks for my friends.
- Not right now, thank you.
Nice meeting you.
C'mon honey.
- Hiya Candy.
- Get your wet paws off me.
- You tramp.
You're a no good tramp.
- So? Go sit down.
- It's a very beautiful flower.
- Yeah, beautiful.
- Carlos, you got no soul.
Why is she here?
- Because she's going south
with the take, that's why.
- You're a stinking liar.
- Temper, temper.
How do you know?
- Two reasons.
Where else you get this kind of dough?
- So I saved it, you big ape.
- Please.
And?
- And we got a beef from a customer.
Claims he was rolled.
Oh?
- Dutch, you know me better than that.
Do I?
- Well, don't you?
- I'm not sure, Candy,
I'm not sure at all.
When I'm not sure I worry,
and I don't like to worry.
Lou.
- Yes?
- Where's she working?
- The Topper.
- Get another girl over there.
- But Dutch?
- And take her off the
payroll for a while.
- Dutch, you can't do this.
- You better muss her face up a little bit
so she can't work any place.
- No, Dutch.
Dutch, I didn't cheat
you, honest I didn't.
You gotta believe me.
- Sure, I believe you. Almost.
Maybe it's a good thing.
Maybe if you go hungry for a while,
you'll remember that
honesty's the best policy.
Lou?
- Dirty rotten.
- It's too bad.
It's too bad.
People got to get greedy.
Just got to get greedy.
Any other business today?
Carlos has got a surprise for you.
- This is Mary Smith, Dutch.
- Maw Smith, huh?
There's so many of you.
- That's really my name, Mr. Becker.
- Yeah, sure.
Where are you from Mary?
- Akron. That's in Ohio.
- Yeah, I know.
How old are you?
- Twenty one.
- That's good.
That's good.
Well, you're a very beautiful girl, Mary.
- Thank you. Mr. Becker.
- Carlos?
- Yeah Dutch?
- Show her the ropes.
Put her on over at The Topper.
Get her some new clothes
and surely we can find a better
name than Mary Smith, huh?
- Thank you, Mr. Becker.
Thank you very much.
- It's a pleasure, Maw.
Remember this, I only ask two things:
Honesty and loyalty.
I must have loyalty, hmm?
- What's the deal, Casey?
- What do you mean?
- You're nervous, nervous as a cat.
- So, I don't sleep good nights.
- Now, when you asked me
to have a drink with you,
I was pretty happy.
Now, I don't know.
All my life, I've had dreams.
Not big ones,
just my share of the little things.
Have someone like me, really like me.
Maybe even respect me.
Someone I could take care of, love,
I know I'm no bargain,
I've been around plenty.
I don't feel sorry for myself.
Only sometimes I get the feeling
there isn't any more time.
There isn't gonna be any tomorrow.
Be nice to me, Casey.
Please.
- Here.
You know, we're two of a kind.
You never got a break and
I never asked for one.
So here's to us.
Win, lose, or draw, here's to us.
- You mean it?
- Well, I don't know very
much about being nice,
but for you, I'll try.
- Casey.
- World might end for both of us
tonight, tomorrow, or next week.
You gotta remember that.
- We could go away, Casey.
Forget Dutch.
We'll go to another town and start living.
- First thing you gotta learn is this:
win, lose or draw, I call the play.
- Okay Casey, you call the play.
- I met Dutch, seemed to like me.
- Make him love you.
Live it up, spend some money.
- You got any money?
- Interesting magazine, look it over.
- How's Lucille?
- She's rough. She wants to see you.
- Okay.
- I like a man who reads, shows he thinks.
I like a man who thinks.
- Hi Dutch.
- Small world.
Meet Carlos Armor, Big Joe Walters.
- Hi.
- Can we give you a lift?
- No thank you, I feel like walking.
- That's good.
You guys ought gonna walk more.
I like you.
Maybe we do business, maybe
you come to work for me.
- Maybe.
- Come around and see me, we'll talk.
He was so right.
I'd be down to see him soon, real soon.
I was gonna stick closer
to him than his breath,
but first I had to see Lucille.
Lucille?
Lucille.
- Hi, Casey.
- How ya doing?
- You don't know.
You don't know.
- Yes I do.
- No, you don't know.
You can't know.
They're giving it to me
all at once, kill or cure.
I don't know yet which way it's going.
- You're gonna be all right.
- How's Junie?
- Oh, she's fine. She's just fine.
- I'm scared, Casey.
I'm scared.
It's hell.
There's no hell like it.
None like it.
- You're gonna be all
right, I promise you.
Honey, I've got to go.
The nurse said I could just stay
long enough to say hello.
- Is there room in the
world for people like us?
Is there?
- There's plenty of room
for all of us, Lucille.
Almost all of us.
- If I get well, can we be together more?
I need someone.
I'm not strong, Casey.
I need someone to help me.
- I'm gonna give you
all the help you need.
Maybe Dutch
wasn't sure of me yet.
Maybe Carlos and Big Joe
talked him out of it.
Anyway, he didn't repeat
his offer of a job,
but I built it slow and easy,
just like the government boys told me to.
I took my time and I waited.
I got to know Dutch and his mob,
and the better I knew them,
the more I hated them.
I'd lived my whole life with hoods.
One thing they respect is guts,
so I was going to give
it to them in spades.
- You're two people, aren't you, Casey?
- Who isn't?
- Yeah, who isn't?
Well, they're all here tonight.
The worst of them.
Nice company we're keeping.
- Well, you don't go to
church to make a fast buck.
Where'd you get that halo all of a sudden?
- Halo, me?
Oh, it's pretty funny.
Oh, we're Penny Annie
alongside this bunch.
- You with me or against me?
Sorry Casey,
I guess I'm just tired.
- Want me to take you home?
I go when you go.
- Pataruski yet.
- There's a very interesting young man.
He's gonna be a very useful young man.
- What do you know about him, Dutch?
Outside of Gladys brought him down here.
- He's all right.
I had him screened, like they say.
He's all right, could use him.
Lou?
- Yeah, yeah Dutch?
- Bring him over.
- Take your hands off me.
- Boss wants to see you.
- Tell him I'll be right over.
- Boss wants to see you, now.
- Casey!
- I told you
to keep your hands off me.
- Break it up, break it up!
Put it away, Lou.
Go on home, Lou.
I'll talk to you later.
- I said, go home Lou.
All right, back to your party.
Right now!
You, you shouldn't cause
trouble Mr. Martin.
- You tell that moron to
keep his hands off me.
- I don't take orders, I give them.
Come on, we'll talk.
Casey, you've had a lot to drink.
Let's go home, we'll talk tomorrow.
- We'll talk now.
You come along, you can listen.
Please.
Sit down, Gladys.
What are you trying to prove,
that you're tough?
- I'm tough enough.
- Always remember one thing, Casey;
there's somebody tougher than you.
- Prove it.
-Hmm.
Well, maybe you're the exception.
- You know I could do you a lot of good.
You need me.
Maybe you don't like me, but you need me.
- But I do like you.
But what makes you think I need you?
- You're a big man, Dutch.
You need a big man around you, strong man.
You need me.
- Maybe you make sense.
Drink your drink.
- Don't you think you've
had enough tonight?
- I can handle it.
There isn't much I
can't handle, huh Dutch?
- Well, that's what you say.
- You got a big lip.
Carlos, I
drive you nuts, don't I?
You can't figure me.
And you, Big Joe.
You don't get me, do you?
- I don't want to.
- Keep talking, loud mouth.
- Big!
Spirit, I like.
Trouble, I don't like.
If you're gonna work for me,
there's one thing you gotta learn.
There's no percentage in us
fighting among ourselves.
No percentage at all.
I'm a very mild man, Casey.
Violence, I don't like,
unless it's necessary.
You think you can remember that?
- I'll try.
- Good.
Meet me here tomorrow night.
Now, go along home and
get yourself a good sleep.
See you tomorrow.
- Someday I'm gonna kill that guy.
- You're not gonna kill anybody,
unless I tell you to.
Big, call a cab.
It's getting late.
- Hand me the phone, will you?
- Burns?
- Yo.
- Rogers.
Casey just left, do I
tail him or stay here?
Stay with him. He's alone?
No, Gladys Baker's with him.
Stick right with him,
check back in an hour.
They go home?
- Yeah, I think so.
Okay.
- Right.
The next morning,
I had another meet with the treasury men.
The place was the Blue Gull Kitchen
over on East 10th Street.
So far I was out in front,
but I had a feeling that
something was wrong.
Somehow I sensed it.
They were waiting for me,
Cooper, Amory, Sullivan and Wheeler.
- Just coffee, thank you.
What's wrong?
- You see Jim Rogers last night?
- Yep.
- Where'd you see him last?
- Torch Club, why?
- We just saw Mrs. Rogers.
- So?
- We had to tell her that he was dead.
- Dead?
How did they spot him?
- We don't know if they did,
maybe it was just an accident.
- Accident!
I wish I knew how much
they got out of him.
- Nothing, if I know Jim.
Anyway, we've got to take that chance.
- Thank you.
- You wanna quit now?
- No.
-All right, how'd you make out?
- I gotta meet with Dutch tonight.
Think I demonstrated
that I can handle myself.
He'll go for me.
- Good.
When we move in, I don't
want to guess I wanna know.
I wanna smash the whole
rotten ring at once.
- You'd better.
Anything else?
- That's all for now.
- Are you mad?
- No, Honey.
Look, Gladys, I told you
before: it won't be long.
Whatever happens, it won't be long.
Just get outta town and stay
there until I send for you.
- When do you think that'll be?
- Soon.
Oh, don't kid yourself, Casey.
Once you start with Dutch Becker,
you're in it as long as he wants you.
Don't argue with me.
Casey, I can't let you do it.
I'm not gonna let you make money this way.
That's why I
wanted to meet with Dutch.
You knew that.
- I know, but I like you too much.
I can't let you do it.
Casey, you'll learn to hate yourself.
Someday this will destroy you.
Oh, you don't know
what you're talking about.
- I don't?
Well, I'll tell you something:
I know plenty.
I can tell the cops
plenty about Dutch Becker.
I'll blow the whistle
and blow this whole set up sky high.
- Shut up, Gladys.
- Don't tell me to shut up,
I know what I'm talking about.
I worked for Dutch.
I worked for Dutch for a long time.
- Please, please get out
of town and stay there.
- I'd never do anything
to hurt you, Casey.
- Hi, Jack.
Dutch in?
- Nobody's in.
- That's funny, I was
supposed to meet him here.
- Did you try the warehouse?
- Should I?
- Yeah, he called.
Told me to send you over there.
- Where is it?
- Third Avenue and Second Street, 207.
- Buy you a drink?
- It's bad enough to have to look at it.
This was the
beginning or the end, or both.
You could take your pick.
It was even money any
way you looked at it.
Once I walked down that alley
and into that warehouse,
there was no turning back.
The warehouse was as dark
and as still as death.
I had a choice: life in prison,
or the very good chance
of a bullet in the head.
I had no future either way.
I know now how a condemned man feels
when he takes that last long walk
to the little door at the end of the hall.
Hi Dutch.
Got a cool head now, I hope.
- Yeah, cool enough.
I want you two to knock it off.
I need you both.
- We'll get along,
won't we Casey?
- Take a walk, Lou.
Got a lot of money stacked up here.
Behave yourself and
you can get part of it.
Be smart, take orders.
I like you.
- Whiskey?
- Good whiskey.
Bonded.
I ought to know, I bonded it myself.
- Yeah, you ought to know.
- This is just a sideline compared to
my other lines of merchandise.
I brought you down here
'cause I think you're good
at selling and delivering.
Emptying a truckload of whiskey.
- Yeah, I get along.
- Yeah, I know.
I don't ever make a move, Casey,
until I'm sure of my man.
You're all right.
- Thanks.
- Start you off here
and you do a good job,
I'll move you on to bigger things, okay?
- Okay.
I'll turn my customer over to you.
He wants 200 cases of bourbon.
- I like the way you operate, Casey.
When's he want delivery?
- Well, I don't know.
I'll have to contact him and find out.
- You do that.
Come on, we go downstairs.
I wanna show you something.
Lou!
I go nowhere with him.
- I go nowhere without him.
Let's go.
Twenty five gallons of 180
proof alcohol every hour.
25 gallons of rot gut.
- Well, some isn't, some isn't.
Depends on who we sell it to.
And what about my client?
- The very best, naturally.
Fifteen thousand gallons a
month is approximately $150,000.
Not a bad sideline, huh Casey?
Mm!
- Yeah?
- Casey?
- Yeah.
- Johnny Cooper.
Yeah.
- Get out on the corner of
Fifth and Burton right away,
I'll have a car pick you up.
- What for?
We found a body.
It could be Gladys Baker.
- Okay, I'll be right down.
Right.
Well?
- It's Gladys.
- Let's go, Casey.
I'm sorry Casey.
- Why did they do that to her face?
All she wanted was someone to love her.
- The question is, why did they kill her?
Maybe I better get you off the job,
get you out of town.
- You want him on a bootleg rap?
- That'll do.
-All right, but I'm
gonna tell you one thing:
when I get through with him,
maybe you won't have anybody left to book.
- Yeah?
Dutch?
- Who's this?
Casey, can [see you?
- Where you been?
I've been trying to get you.
- I've been busy.
Listen Mr. Martin,
you're working for me.
Keep yourself available.
- Keep your shirt on.
I talked to my contact,
when can I see you?
- Be here at eight o'clock tonight.
You're the boss.
- Don't you forget it.
Well, on time for a change.
That's good.
- You ought to print time cards.
- Very sharp stuff, Casey.
Very sharp stuff.
- Yeah, Case always has to cause a laugh.
Didn't you, Case?
- Get away from me.
- Sit down, Lou.
When's he want delivery?
- Saturday morning, early, 5:00 AM.
- Ah, what's he want?
- 200 cases of bourbon.
- You get the seven Gs from
him, he gets the bourbon.
- Okay, I'll see you around.
- Yeah, you do that if you have time, huh?
- He wants 200 cases, Saturday
morning, early 5:00 AM.
- That's great.
- He wants the seven G's first.
- I thought he would.
Here.
- Marked?
- Plenty.
Make your delivery to the Sussex bar,
9300 Railroad Avenue.
We'll have a man in front for you.
- Anything else?
- Boys at the lab
found some fingerprints on that trunk.
- Yeah, who's?
- Lay off Terpe, Casey,
or you'll blow this plan sky high.
I've got a hunch we're gonna
have to move fast, now.
I didn't care if
everything blew sky high.
I didn't care if the
world ended now, tonight.
I had one thing to do, only one.
- What's the matter?
Casey, you crazy or something?
Why did you do it?
- Why'd I do What?
What'd I do?
You crazy, Casey!
- You killed Gladys, why?
Why?
I don't know.
-Why?
- Dutch told me to do it, Case!
Dutch told me to do it!
- Casey!
- Oh, you're lucky.
You're real lucky.
I'm all right.
- You better get outta here, fast.
Well, what do we do now?
- We'll book him for being disorderly.
Well he is, isn't he?
- Yeah, he's disorderly.
- So we book him.
- Hello.
Casey?
- Yeah.
- Get down here right
away, we've got to see you.
- Well, that's taking
quite a chance, isn't it?
- Can't help it, we've got to take it.
- "We?"
Okay, I'll be right down.
What's the matter?
- I suppose I could ask
you that, but I won't.
Terpe is conscious and crying
his eyes out for a mouthpiece.
He's in bad shape.
We slapped a no visitor tag on him,
but word will get out.
Can you switch delivery
to tomorrow morning?
- I'll try.
- Here, we got something for you.
- Short wave transmitter.
Now this is the aerial.
You put one line over,
back between your shoulder blades
and one down through your sleeve.
It has a radius of six blocks.
All you do is switch it
on, put it in your pocket.
We'll be listening.
- Dutch sees that, I'm dead!
- Just be careful, he won't.
- I like your confidence.
- Put this on just
before you make delivery.
Our sound truck will
re-broadcast your position
and your conversation to us.
- We're in the stretch, Casey.
If everything goes well,
the next couple of days should end it.
Usually a man
gets by with five senses,
sometimes he gets a sixth.
I had it now.
I know of 11 murders that
could be traced to Dutch.
As I crossed the floor to him,
I had the feeling that maybe
he was going to try for an even dozen.
- What's the idea?
Boys got worried.
- What about?
- You.
- Why?
- Lou Terpe's in the prison
ward of the general hospital.
Any idea how he got there?
- Or how come he mentioned
your name in a loud voice
before he passed out?
- We're listening, Casey.
- Casey likes to talk with his fists.
Maybe you ought to listen for a while.
- Talk.
- Okay Dutch.
I know what happened to Gladys.
- So?
- Terpe got drunk.
He told me that he killed her,
then he nailed me.
Maybe she deserved to die, maybe not.
I don't know.
But I went crazy and the
cops came and I beat it.
It's lucky I didn't kill him.
That's the whole story.
- That's all the story?
- Dutch, I'm in this
business to make money.
I got seven grand in my pocket.
If you don't wanna do business with me,
I'll take it elsewhere.
- Carlos.
Put it back.
It's like I told you,
you tie up with me,
you don't make trouble.
Here, wipe your face.
Gladys was dangerous.
You can't afford to get soft, right?
- I'll tell my contact it's no deal.
- Wait a minute.
Who said it was no deal?
Gimme the money.
- Now he wants tomorrow morning, 5:00 AM.
Tomorrow at 5:00 AM.
Where do we make the delivery?
- Sussex bar, 9300 Railroad Avenue.
- Okay, 200 cases, Sussex Bar 5:00 AM.
You take care of it.
- Okay, I'll take care of it.
That's the way it's done.
Pick him up.
You ain't in good condition.
- You gonna make a deal with him?
- Well, I ain't gonna throw
seven G's down the drain
because you're nervous.
Go clean yourself up, you look terrible.
Put a tail on Casey and keep him there
and make sure it's somebody he don't know.
- Right.
- I liked him, liked him a lot.
Makes me sad to think
he'd try and hurt me.
I think maybe I go with
you in the morning.
- I think that might be a good idea.
- Shut up.
- Burns, Sussex bar at 5:00 AM.
They're delivering 200 cases.
- Good work.
- They're nervous.
Terpe got word out.
They gave me a going over,
but I think I squared the beef.
- Don't worry about Terpe, he's in a coma.
He won't be talking to
anybody for a while.
Relax. See ya.
- You better be there, Cooper.
My friends are still outside.
I'm going out now.
It's like you say,
this should be the end
one way or the other.
See you soon, I hope.
I also hope I'm coming in clear.
- What's your problem?
- Boss wants to give you a lift.
- Watch the warehouse.
We'll call you later.
- What's that for?
- So you shouldn't hurt yourself.
- What's the beef?
What are you down here for?
- He's worried.
I make money, Casey.
I make a lot of money.
My organization makes money
because I trust people.
I hire people, I pay 'em good,
then I expect them to work for me.
If they don't, I still
pay them, but personally.
I'm sensitive, my feelings get hurt.
What's the matter, you crazy?
- They're not going to warehouse.
Something's gone sour.
- Cars one and three,
are you reading Casey?
- Car three, Roger.
- Car one, Roger.
- Third and Main.
- Alright, we're moving out.
Our latest fix is Third and Main.
- Keep talking, Casey. Keep talking.
- It's all clear.
- That's what you think, Dutch.
- Come on, get off the grudge.
- What's the idea?
- Maybe I'm psychic.
Then again, maybe I'm crazy.
What's the matter, you ticklish?
- Keep your fat hands to yourself.
- All right, what's the angle?
- No angle, maybe I
think you're not loyal.
Maybe I think you're a stool pigeon.
-And maybe you're nuts.
- We'll know soon.
We'll make a call in a little while.
Maybe there'll be cops
all over the warehouse,
all around the Sussex bar.
You think?
What have you been smoking?
Anyway, they
don't find anything.
Everything is clean.
Dutch is clean.
You, Casey? Disappear.
The cops think you ran out on them.
So maybe I'm wrong, we'll see.
If I'm wrong, you've got
nothing to worry about, right?
- That's right.
Where are we going?
For a drive.
There ought to be
a prettier place to drive
than Fifth and Broadway.
- Cars one and three, keep close.
Fifth and Broadway.
- Mr. Martin doesn't like the scenery.
Maybe he'll be around
long enough to enjoy it.
But don't worry about it.
You know, I don't like to worry.
- That's why you had
Gladys killed, wasn't it?
- Yeah.
Yeah, that's why I had Gladys killed.
- Good work, Casey.
- You just fried yourself, Dutch.
- No loose ends, huh Dutch?
- No loose ends.
- That's what I like about you, Dutch.
You're smart and you're big.
- You've got no idea how big,
or how dangerous it is to try and hurt me.
Pull around the corner Big.
Make our call now.
- One question.
- Go ahead.
- How big are you?
- I own men and women, Casey.
All over the country, I own 'em.
Some of 'em like to gamble,
some of 'em like to drink,
but I own 'em body and soul.
I own them.
Right?
Carlos!
- Cooper, 10th and Broadway, fast!
- Let's go.
- Carlos, leave him alone.
Get out of here, fast!
- I'm gonna kill you, Dutch.
Now you're gonna know how Gladys felt,
only with you it's gonna take longer.
Casey!
- Come on, get up.
- From now on, he's
living on borrowed time.
- Come on, let's go.
Move!
- You all right?
- Yeah.
- It's all over.
Come on, lemme take care of that head.
- No, I'm all right.
- You sure? Lemme drive you home.
- You go ahead.
- Okay.
Well, we got the big boy.
Now watch the rats run.
Yes, it was all over.
The job was done for Cooper
and the rest of them.
For me, I don't know.
Maybe the rats will run, maybe they won't.
Maybe I'll have a chance to do
some of the things I should
have done a long time ago,
helping people like Lucille and Junie.
I know that I want to
make something of my life.
I'm going to try.
I hope I live long enough to prove it.